what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sockin super pumped
to be talking about global enlightenment
we have Sperry Andrews joining us on the
show hi Sperry well I'm great to be here
thank you so much for coming on the
program really appreciate it
thank you I'm very grateful to Ori
Shapiro for introducing us and help me
make this episode happen yeah me too
yeah he's a fabulous guy yes yes and
there's been great friend of ours major
asset and helping us enlighten yeah for
those who don't know Sperrys background
he has 40 years of experience with
humanity's capacity to share a commonly
sensed consciousness he believes our
interconnectedness is meant to be felt
and thought intuitively by every human
being he's founder and co-director of
the human connection Institute advisory
board member of the lifeboat foundation
and research partner of the
consciousness quotient Institute and you
can find all three of the links in the
bio below Sperry
must start things off with this question
it's something that we're so passionate
about and I'm super interested to hear
your thoughts on it
who are we why are we even here where
did we come from
where are we going what is the nature of
this reality yes these are questions
that just instinctively as a living
breathing human being wanted to
understand having had a near-death
experience when I was four and
inadvertently found out what what exists
beyond human life as as that which is
deathless and cannot be destroyed or is
timeless and ever-present as formless
consciousness existing without a body
harder mind as
essentially non-existence and sort of
poised between existence and
non-existence as this awakeness this
colorless light of consciousness and and
that really set you know set the stage
at the age of four to really wonder
about the answers to your question what
does it mean deathlessness and what does
it mean that this consciousness
permeates everything and that what does
is that all that is is that the creation
itself is that deathless aliveness all
permeating can you unpack what you felt
and mm-hmm
how you continue feeling it yes well
maybe I'll start with a something that
has been said for centuries or thousands
of years that by sages and satyrs and
Yogi's that if in life one dies to who
they think they are then when they
physically die they don't die so that's
in the literature and there's this part
of us which is uncreated they say we're
unborn and in that sense we were
indestructible and immortal or
ever-present were part of the
omnipresent omnipotent omniscient that
has been talked about in various
religions and so forth and various with
various words well what it is is that
what has been denied by reductionistic
science is that which is not anything at
all yet there are physicists like Alex
Vilenkin and allowing Guth and even
Stephen Hawking and others have said yes
we can have a universe that have arises
out of nothing
that in quantum mechanics you can borrow
an infinite amount of energy for an
infinite amount of time as long as you
you know return it back to that which is
nothing whatsoever well even the most
conservative astrophysicists are pretty
much an agreement that in order to have
the universe that we have it had to have
originated from nothing at all and the
amazing property of that which is
nothing whatsoever is that it being
nothing it cannot be divided against
itself that can't not be divided from
itself and so if you imagine that that
which is dimensionless can take form as
a coordinate location as a dimensionless
point which is still undivided from all
that is dimensionless and nothing
whatsoever but now it's a dimensionless
point as a coordinate location as the in
the origin of space and time well what
this causes a virtual equal and opposite
forces to take place for potentials that
cancel to zero around this point and
that moments this inflation of more
dimensionless points that are held
together by these virtual potentials and
this is what it looks like is the only
thing that really makes sense for the
origins of space time energy and matter
so essentially you have space which is
made of the it was as a geometry of
these points so imagine how many
incident number of points can make up
space its countless that's why it's
infinite and yet these points are still
fundamentally indivisible as if they
were a single point and in the physics
of our three dimensions our three
dimensions actually every point in three
dimensions actually share a sin
polar point in what is called the fourth
dimension of space which is just a
single dimensionless point where all
points in three dimension all coordinate
locations share that single point so
that single point has an instantaneous
presence throughout all of three
dimensional space-time that coordinates
all electromagnetic and gravitational
forces which are in many respects equal
in opposite forces all points expand
kinetically to all other points
that's electromagnetic radiation and all
points collapsing towards every single
point is gravitation but because the
spaciousness of the universe is made up
of a countless number of points there's
no way for their universe to actually
collapse to a single point because now
it's an infinite number of points that
are are the extent of my latest
estimates two trillion galaxies which
are expanding at an ever-increasing rate
by best estimates okay so we go from a
initial creation into upcoming aliveness
and complexity arising and that there is
some sort of a way for us to potentially
understand at a reductionist level what
that source code initially was and how
it evolved this complexity and how its
continuing to evolve this aliveness that
includes conscious creatures like
ourselves studying it studying creation
that's right because that the
description of the this dynamic
recreative structure is being reunited
by what is structureless and indivisible
so everything that emerges from what is
indivisible and is structuralist and
dimensionless
has to be reunited and reunited
representing itself as space and time
ultimately energy matter and mind and
body down the line and what it all
shares that same dynamic of being a form
essentially evolving towards having the
same characteristics of what is formless
in Zen it said no form is formlessness
formlessness is form
so these seeming opposites are actually
equivalents and if we look at that there
that if this is now I can do this to the
camera if this is formlessness and this
is form and this form is having to be
reunited and represented and regenerated
and recreated because it is made out of
what is formless if we put the two
together and see them as a non duality
as a as an indivisible whole the phase
transition similar to how when water
turns to steam it has a transition point
where it's both water and more gaseous
more where the molecules more spread
apart the thing that that that the the
inner the interstitial aspect which is a
dynamic aspect between form of
formlessness is what we experience as
consciousness or or the unmanifest
origin of of life because it continues
to cause form to reconnect and re be
regenerated and recreated and yet it is
not a thing it's just a done a process
that causes form to reconnect and and
represent itself in some new
incomparably unique way so billions of
times a second by comparing at it in a
quarter mechanical level so creation is
embedded with both formlessness and form
and
then the forum it takes its place in our
world as the material physical world
where we're trying to do the mind/body
we're now we're also trying to do the
science spirit which this is the kind of
leads into the question how can science
then poke at the formless and is the
formless animism is it all this spirit
well it's the let's say the witness
everything is a byproduct of awareness
in our experience I mean so is there a
you're aware honest my awareness you
know at one level there is but at
another level there's only one
consciousness there's only one
mirror-like quality that is omnipresent
that is allowing everything to be re
revital you know recreated fresh and new
billions of times a second so that is
formed into what this evolution of human
beings and sentient creatures in the
universe ultimately in bugs and leaves
and plants and so forth so there are a
lot of they're all utilizing the same
capacity to be reinvented essentially by
the quality and presence of this
awakeness which is like a mirror which
in our bathroom would receive our image
and reflect it back to us without having
an image of its own so if we can imagine
that your awareness and my awareness at
some level are imageless like when you
try to get to know like who are we what
are we you can't find in neuroscience
you can't find the observer you can't
find a witness because it's not a thing
it's a process it's an emergent
phenomena well it's the thing is about
the void which is really your the void
I'm the void we are the void witnessing
what can change as that which does not
change
so we're the same awareness that we were
in utero and all throughout our lives do
you feel like you're a different
awareness now I mean the content the
quality the the intelligence of your
mind and heart and body have evolved
yeah but is how's your awareness of alt
who you are as awake awareness so
pointing at that feel how it actually
brings us into a kind of a felt sense we
had to use our nonverbal bodies hearts
and minds together to focus our
awareness on what has been pointed to
with these words and we enter into that
sense of being heartfelt together and
that sense of sharing undivided
attention
yeah is what humans they crave that
we're starving for that sense of
interconnectedness you know belonging
yes to life to one another to being
meaningful to one another yes and when
our parents acknowledge and they love us
they hold or hold us to their heart if
they did and we feel them feeling us and
and they feel us feeling them that sense
of undivided attention
is nothing but unconditional love so
it's undivided attention or indivisible
awakeness you is the source of this
communion that we call love and we crave
that it's like a nerd nerd no a
nourishment it's an essential nutrient
yes so in the same way that plants need
sunlight in order to grow then all the
cells at a plant they all need to be
synergizing together and connecting
together constantly in ever fresh new
ways in order to be vitally alive and
grow to become something other than a
seed same way we come from as I a single
zygote when in consumption and and now
we went from a single cell to now being
made
on average about 50 trillion human cells
and in some cases as many 20 times as
many bacterial cells that are non-human
and so your 50 trillion human cells of
my 50 trillion is 200 trillion human
cells and then about you know 450
trillion
you know bacterial cells and years of
mine that's like 900 trillion so there's
a lot of cell cellular metabolism any we
have in our microbiomes 450 trillion you
know about 20 times as many 50 times 10
to 20 times as many as we have human
cells so all of that in the and the
Cambrian explosion goes back not quite
600 million years ago everything was
basically single-cell organisms on the
planet that was such a profound moment
for civilization to have evolved was the
Cambrian explosion just know life in
general awakening consciousness evolving
life evolving the Cambrian explosion was
pretty much like the most important
moment one of them yeah well the
evidence the fossil evidence shows that
for about 2 billion years before then we
were all single-cell you know if we were
if there was any life at all it was seen
to be single-cell phytoplankton and it
took that 2 billion years of that
phytoplankton
utilizing the available elements to take
in carbon dioxide and produce oxygen to
create our atmosphere so a life couldn't
really be evolved much beyond you know
single-cell organisms until there was a
livable atmosphere and that could
support more complex life forms and at
that point cells begin to realize that
they could survive and thrive better by
collaborating but there was also a
condition
yeah competition collaboration seems to
have happened at stages a competition
for a while
made things move forward but then that
could only go so far and then it life
would actually collapse back into a more
cooperative form yeah and Elizabeth's a
Taurus who's an absolute brilliant
person like Lynn Margulis and others who
have studied the origins of life talked
about this these stages of cooperation
and collaboration that you know went
sort of hand and hand in glove for quite
a while now then a whole different
question is what actually caused these
moments right within creation what what
forces are at play that actually created
this Cambrian explosion er that created
this asteroid colliding with the planet
when the dinosaurs were here that then
gave space for humans to evolve but
putting that question to the side I'd
like to revisit this as we were
mentioning it there's this marriage
that's happening in a sense in within
creation between science and spirit and
when we tap into this unity
consciousness this interconnectedness of
everything we see it so much now
especially in our world where you
mentioned this a little bit ago there's
such a strong desire for belonging such
a strong desire for alive in us for my
unique gifts and talents and gems to be
brought forth into the world so that
again I can feel the community I can
feel the belonging so then what are
right now would you say are these like
main ways of perceiving and also
perceiving what's happening and why it's
happening and also some of the ways that
we can then do the process of feeling
that belonging feeling that
interconnectedness experiencing that
unity consciousness is this like an ebb
and flow it feels like an ebb and flow
like it feels like that at any moment I
can go and just like
into unity consciousness mm-hmm but then
at any moment I can also snap back into
like my physical form where I'm a
physical being talking to another nerve
ending of God and we're just like that
is is how do you how do you feel about
mmm you know those are two very valuable
and valid well your suffix feeling and
naming what it is that is true for us
well first let's look at the fact that
the universe has been expanded seemingly
from a point a dimensionless point
something even smaller than a proton it
seems that is our guests best guests now
when we realized that the expansion was
caused by the fact that observation
caused a measurement structure which is
spatial temporal so that spatial
temporal measurement structure gave rise
to the next more refined observation
this indivisible void bringing it all
together again actually began to have
form like a mind will bring together and
focus awareness so let's say you have
awareness and you have the mind in this
case of maybe God or whatever or the
universe and you have the form that's
resulting the measurement the
spatio-temporal structure that results
from the mind focusing that which is
formless illness evening to reunite in
ever more refined ways what is evolving
as physical okay so does the mind act as
a medium between the formless and then
the form well it's just an it's a more
virtual structure let's say it's a
virtual the definition of virtual is
that it's it's very much like the real
electron or photon or whether it's just
the it's transitory it appears and
disappears
it's more like a field or a potential
okay so it's more formless it's more
like between formlessness and form it's
an it's an interstitial structure that
is that is linking the twos as a field
of potential is the mind is the
potential so that the we basically
collapse all that is into some sort of a
physical moment when we bring our mind
to it we collapse it into a physical
experience that we intake as mind or we
could call of collapse or radiated or
waiting we can resonate with you know
everything you can possibly imagine
basically but if you see that the
expanse of the universe is due to the
fact that this indivisibility that is
fundamental to the void is going to
cause this evolution of observational
measurement processes so that each
observation leads to it the next
iteration of measurements which are
spatial temporal structures you have the
expansion of the universe being the
expansion of consciousness so here we
are today expanding our consciousnesses
by seeing what can make sense to us what
you know what is our commonly sensed
consciousness right now and it's
invigorating to share in a mutually
understandable way what is we
non-verbally sense and feel which is
almost ninety seven percent of of what
we are and so our sensory intelligence
and our emotional intelligence is
largely nonverbal mediated by our right
brain this new brain the new kid on the
block the verbal analytic brain is
trying to make a conceptual map of what
is non-verbally sensed and felt by you
and I
at a nonverbal level we're in this Telus
ematic potential mind which is sensing
you know does this making sense you know
at a verbal analytic level you know and
we're tuning and feeling into that you
know and and so we've been doing that
since we were little children we were
like is our mom and dad really telling
the truth I mean are they insane or are
they completely like on Botswana land
you know are they totally off the grid
into their robot land of who they think
they are what they think they're doing
and as little children we could sort of
detect that they've become kind of rigid
and you know they're living according to
their hypnotism z-- and their cultural
conditionings and everything else and
with fresh and new starting starting the
whole process all over again as a new
sentient you know a life-form
maybe we're incarnated you know hundreds
of thousands of times so we get a
Mindwipe and we start over again in
order to go on the journey and see what
happens this time so yeah it's very
complex and very simple in some ways so
many adventures of consciousness and
like how you describe with the with the
children that the mind is so much like
looking at the parents going like why is
your mind so constrained to the hip
hypnotized by the economic machinery and
all these other influences on you
meanwhile we as adults we look back with
nostalgia at our childhood because we
adore what it was like to be so free
mm-hmm
and that freeness also feels like it's
all permeating all the time around us
and that we can its direct to access all
the time but we're in a sense just in in
the physical form and a hat and if you
haven't had an experience of non
separation from the one then you feel
like you're constantly separate and then
that
the need for for wanting to dominate or
own or greed or for any of these
malevolent issues that we have our
separation from the one is what is
causing all of the symptoms that exist
in our in our society very well said
absolutely you know so the work that
I've been doing the last 40 years is how
to bring people into that same quality
of unity consciousness that we felt when
we were little I mean nature created us
to feel that we were indivisible from
the whole of existence I mean our
parents were like part of us we just
imagine they must feel that we're part
of them obviously but then they
objectified us as good little girl good
little boy yeah this is your mommy this
is your daddy you know is your sister
your there and the crib stay there don't
go to sleep now you know so we were
objectified and and then that was
terrifying and then those tremendous
trauma to feel like we were you know
being told that we were chefs and
isolated interested by these giants that
are we we feel indivisible from that
literally bruised were that what we came
through the world through them and tell
us that we are separated I really just
appreciate how you use the word trauma I
think that's very important here that um
upon this birth and early formative
years literally so much of the most
important oral architecture is laid down
in those early formative years that if
we're constantly being fed by every our
closest parents friends family etc but
also society at large separation
separation separation separation
separation you're it's in its inevitably
going to have that traumatic effect
versus trying to be born with the
oneness you are one with us with the
world so we have to survive though I
mean we as plants and animals I mean we
had to demarcate or separate physical
territory our food my dad my children
would help you don't yell I would you
don't need my babies huh does that mean
my wasn't that the root of so many of
the issues that we had was that we
started using that phrase this is the
body my house yeah but in order to have
a physical body you see we have to
nourish ourselves we have to survive as
a physical creature emotional creature
and so we have to defend from the fact
that the you know the seagull wants to
eat the babies or the eggs of the other
bird or whatever there's the constant
battle in nature we've all watched the
nature programs I mean everything is
eating and being eaten by everything
else so as human beings of me we've had
to survive hundreds of millions of years
of eating and being eaten by each other
in our or neurological you know history
so there's a knee-jerk kind of like fear
of like oh I have a boundary you don't
eat me I may eat you but you're not
going to eat me and so there's that
battle over over physical territory and
that turned into battles over
psychological territorial a my religion
your religion you know if you don't
believe what I believe I mean the
religions that are so similar so
identical and yet they've been at war
with each other for hundreds of years so
it's completely insane the insanity of
humanity is is the point of of all the
work that I've done is to show that we
can successfully and ASAP resolve the
insanity of humanity and have global
enlightenment yes and the insanity of
humanity is actually a product a feature
of creation that makes this process of
evolution and growth and healing so
gorgeous in the first place yes I mean
we the humbling one can imagine of how
many disappointments how many
heartbreaks we've each had in our lives
I mean of being told that we weren't
good enough or we didn't have it
together or you just don't measure up
and so it's this you have to jump
through so many hoops
you know maybe have somebody admire or
respect you or hopefully love you for
who you who you've become or so it's
very bizarre gauntlet like the Indians
used to you know you had to survive in
the Indian tribe you had to run the
gauntlet they'd all beat you to death
practically and if you survived the
gauntlet of them all hitting you with
stones and sticks then you became a
viable member of the tribe right so life
is a little bit like that and so we've
been you know tenderized let's say
that's a good way to put it we've run
through the gauntlet
it's the cheating and here we are were
the were the byproduct of you know
billions of years of sentient and bio
physical and neurological evolution yeah
and that healing and growth is
SuperDuper evident right now you were
just mentioning how you know the last 40
years of work have been leading you
towards this paradigm of global
enlightenment and human connection and
interconnectedness I would love for you
to read this quote that you have about
about the future and what it is and then
take us down your path about how exactly
you are helping people feel those states
oh well this is just something I thought
I'd bring because it just came out on
Facebook the other day about this man's
work which is in the very much still the
reductionistic science so to have
something like this come out in the very
conservative scientific journal of
Scientific American is a big deal
because I've been working towards
popularizing you know unity
consciousness on the planet
you know as a professional for for
almost 40 years through my Institute and
so here comes this man Miguel Nicolelis
he's has a book called Beyond Boundaries
and he serves on the board of Scientific
American
and his work is described as the merging
of human brain activity he describes it
that way as the future of humanity as
the next stage in our species evolution
merging of human brain activity being
the next step in human evolution yes and
that's an example being something like
this even this dialogue here when you
talk to even just one person do you feel
just your own self or do you also begin
to feel that other person may be do you
feel when they express an emotion of
maybe sadness or happiness do you feel
there is empathy do you feel their
sadness do you feel their happiness I do
I mean I've at age four I experienced
that I was indivisible from everyone and
everything and that's been an integral
part of my conscious awareness ever
since and I'm going just past sixty
eight years a number of months ago so
it's been at least 64 years of
contemplation about you know how you
know what is that what is the import for
for Humanity it seems very clear that
nature has designed us to thrive and
survive better by sharing a common Lea
sense consciousness consciously instead
of so unconsciously yes and that's that
what that example was for you know two
people and then everyone always feels
this I think we have some this is a
really common feeling that people
experience but when you're talking to
someone and then the third person joins
the conversation it shifts dynamics
immediately yeah and so then what about
when you're at a a 1,000 person event or
a 10,000 person event right there's
almost a collective consciousness at
like a music event or a sporting event
or whatever it may be where you're
feeling the essence of the people
they're together and so what I can tell
you about an event with a thousand
people in Central Park
New York City yeah there was a thousand
of us and no to a stage we were all like
sitting on the grass and Allen Ginsberg
had written reciting of some poetry and
then this gal got up there I forgot her
name and she had us all kind of moving
while we were sitting together so we
became aware of our nonverbal bodies
hearts and minds and then at a certain
point where she felt this
interconnectedness she said okay
everybody just mindfully very slowly
just stand up so everybody very slowly
all thousand people all stood up and
that gave us a shared experience because
we were in tuned in from you know
listening to these various presenters
and tuning into them together and then
she had us turn to the next person near
us and feel with them and you don't make
unbroken eye contact and then turn to
another person
very slowly yeah and then another person
and basically a thousand people began to
feel like they were extensions of a
single body heart in mind there's a
greater body heart in mind I love that
that those experiences are so profound
and as are the very long like ten days
like the passion of meditation retreats
were you yourself can feel like you're
in the hall with a hundred and twenty
others and that you're all in this
process of doing this deep beautiful
work together and there's other
experiences like right now in many ways
is there's a very sensitive people on
the planet that are tapped into the
feeling of the increase in in in the
parts per million of co2 in our
atmosphere or in the acidification of
the oceans or when the force do you
could be hum deforested are burned down
that people are tapped into the feeling
of that and that's part of this
collective can you feel the economy
sometimes sperry it really feels like
that when I'm up at night by myself in
flow when the entire half of this planet
is asleep so half of the planet is
asleep the other half of the
planets awaken the roaring economic
machinery is happening but on this half
of the planet when I'm awake at like
between maybe 2:00 and 5:00 a.m. ish
let's say most people are asleep though
economic machineries asleep I feel like
the veil is the thinnest I'm able to
pierce it find my peak flow States and
get a lot of really beautiful it's
because it just feels like that I'm more
deeply connected to the asleep nough
submachine er II and therefore I can
feel like the deeper amount of signal is
coming down for me through through me
and creating into the world and so
there's like these different feelings of
being interconnected with the planet
with animals with other humans at just
two people at a thousand people at all a
billion people yes well actually the
scientific research work has been done
over the last 20 years by Michael
Persinger at Laurentian University where
he is also geophysicist and a
neuroscientist and he's shown that at
night psychic abilities are much
enhanced and and we can be much more
tuned into you know what's going on with
our relatives and friends and whoever we
can do psychic experiments that are much
more demonstrative of our indivisibility
and our ability to share a common sense
consciously and he's also invented ways
to use electromagnetism to put us into
fields such that people in separate
rooms can actually be more telepathic
with each other under those laboratory
conditions to this statistically
significant degree and is helping to
show that even the the the magnetic
fields around the earth are alike our
brains or brains are largely a magnetic
phenomena the way it stores information
and that we store information in the
field on the magnetic field of the earth
and that the magnetic field of the
planet has the capacity to store all of
human history with perfect clarity and
that actually we're learning as we tune
into this more relaxed way of being a
more synergistic way of being in
resonance with everyone and everything
in an indivisible awake away that we are
going to have access to our combined
intelligence which many of the ETS
report that they have it each individual
has access to every one the combined
intelligence of everyone in their
species and they've advocated going back
to Eisenhower that you know to practice
altruistic love to that every act there
every one of their actions is an actor
of out true altruism yes and the more we
act out of this communion the sense of
being one and we're all in this together
and we're collaborating on for the
greater good of all and as one with with
the whole cosmos is an undivided unity
the more we live that way consciously
together the happier we are and the more
meaningful life is and and and we're not
eating and being eaten by each other and
yes we can actually manifest food
through the food replicators with you
know using essential elements or even in
more advanced cases actually out of thin
air so you can have your vichyssoise or
whatever just the way you like it
let the push of a button what would it
look like for our entire species to have
that ability to be able to know the
collective field of others thoughts and
emotions and feelings and this is also
very felt when you you know when you
just do something like when you when you
physically when you inflict harm instead
of love I mean it's people talk about
Karma there's there's very quick
feedback loops that happened with with
when you pass along love and you encode
love into creation versus when you
encode hate so the other thought that I
wanted to pass along to you because so
that we
let's um let's dive into this - well we
know you didn't grow alanine - its it
said that the you know going back to
Sumerian times and so forth that you
know there was a we were impacted by the
desires of other off-planet creatures
that wanted to use us for their purposes
and so forth and they've had been
tinkering with our DNA going back the
the number of years seems to be of
somewhere around 300 thousand years so
we're a byproduct of this tinkering and
these apparently according to Corey good
maybe if anybody's who in the audience
has listened to the cosmic disclosure
projects and all the vetting of Corey
Goode and Emery Smith and David Wilcock
work and and so forth and their mmm name
isn't coming to the that was worked with
ETS for in the and these big projects
that ultimately you know became part of
the Apollo program and what's his name
bill Tompkins who just died the age of
95 he was visited by 80s when he was
three years old and then ultimately was
brought into these natl Douglas and
Boeing and all these different aerospace
companies which are kind of getting this
reverse engineered technology from the
80s and having very much more advanced
technology than we have generally been
allowed to know about because the whole
a UFO phenomena has been suppressed so
completely but there are those insiders
that are being allowed to come forward
and actually protected to come forward
nowadays who have you know spent decades
working with extraterrestrials you know
side by side so it's extraordinary
what's coming forward and to know that
that we're a byproduct of them and and
they say the ETS say we're the universe
is a soul manufacturing facility the
refinement and evolution of souls so our
universe becomes unsold buy souls and so
we have a conscious universe so that's
just like you would like to be conscious
or I would like to be conscious or we
would like to have a conscious society
on this planet so we're not killing and
being killed by each other and all the
horror and insanity of our needless
suffering that when we could be awake
and aware empathically together you know
the ETS want that - because we're they
feel us as indivisible from them and
they've actually been tinkering us to
help us be more emotionally resilient
and be able to deal with the
difficulties with the ETS that are
they're not so friendly with where
they've been fighting with them for
millions of years how do they they've
been taken out so that we might be able
to actually prevail at some level at a
more conscious level with people that
they haven't been able to link with
psychically so there's all there's so
many layers of what is taking place in
the cosmos yes yes and especially this
this viewpoint is so important for for
children and for adults to have is that
you just take yourself off of the planet
and view the planet like an et would and
you know we're just talking about this
de Strama that the planet has went
through the you you feel it if you feel
it here other beings can feel it here as
well so there can be interventions of
all different sorts and types and it can
be a big there's a zoo hypothesis idea
that there's that it's very important to
be very either you know are there
interventions happening or maybe not
maybe we're in a little petri dish and
we want to see how it evolves how does
it feel like there is a simultaneously a
predation farm at times happening on the
planet evil forces coming through
while simultaneously this beautiful
evolutionary school and refinement of
consciousness that's happening at the
same time so these forces that are all
at play here have specific roles or
archetypal roles from creation that are
making this grand challenge exactly what
it is
and you gave this example as well
earlier I wanted to make sure that we
that we passed a little bit of time on
it this this uh you're you're here after
you know forty years of caring about
human connection and interconnectedness
and these feelings these non-separation
feelings so what have been the studies
that you guys have done in trying to
embark on creating more processes that
are familiar with people that they can
endeavor into that can create more of
that feeling of non-separation yes
well because of my profound sense of
indivisibility going to Australia of
meditating finding that even putting the
earth between me and the United States
didn't separate me and the depths of
conscious awareness that I just said
okay there's no escaping this this
purpose is to bring about this quality
of consciousness of interconnectedness
ultimately I was introduced to dr.
William broad was a senior research
associate of the mind science foundation
which is one of the I think the oldest
privately endowed research foundations
studying a human human human animal
human community machine communication
anomalies under controlled conditions
and so I had met with Rupert Sheldrake
and he was doing these staring
experiments there's a there's a book he
created called the seven experiments
that could change the world and he was
inventing these experiments the
anybody could do that virtually no cost
yeah and he was doing these in this
workshop I was in in New York City where
he would have people stare at the backs
of people and and people would try to
decide whether they're being stared at
or not and and there were some
statistical significance to that finding
and I said well Rupert why don't we try
to do this under double-blind conditions
using camera monitor systems where a
person could be stared at without them
having any known way of knowing when or
if they were being stared out while
their autonomic and central nervous
system was being monitored so dr.
William broad was award-winning
experimental psychologist in the field
that people look to him and he passed
away recently he wrote the book distant
metal influence or so distant metal
interactions which is an entire field
now that has been replicated by multiple
laboratories the work that I did with
dr. William broad to the staring reflex
under controlled conditions had was very
highly significant we did it with a
group that was not a trained by me and
they responded without knowing when or
if they were being stared at with by
reacting and becoming on average tense
then I taught did 10 days with another
group same number of people brought them
into this shared awareness feeling and
sensing together and then we tested them
same demographic and then when they were
stared at they were relaxed they
actually opened up and the significance
between the first group in the second
group was 0.004 for which is a very high
significance level point about 1 in 20
is considered significance so that's
what point 0.02
negatives so 0.004 for was very high
significance that this familiarization
with shared sensitivity shifted the the
subject population so profoundly was
quite significant and then other
laboratories were so impressed by that
that even a laboratory like scientific
applications international it does work
for the United States government with
144,000 employees in the neuroscientific
laboratory it was headed by all his name
is not going to come to me he's a
physicist that worked with with Harold
put off and his name is not gonna come
to may was the name of the physicist
that was in charge of the
neuroscientific laboratory he did twenty
years of research for the US government
with no put off who is now the physicist
on the to the Stars Academy which is
putting forward all the extraterrestrial
visitation research from the US Navy and
so forth to show that they're finally
willing to admit that there are
extraterrestrials that are visiting us
and so forth so anybody wants to go look
up to the Stars Academy you can see what
the US government is willing to release
at this point most of the other
governments on the earth have have
released all their files on UFO activity
it's just the u.s. that's been the most
you know reserved about doing that
because essentially when you show that
there are these highly advanced
civilizations whose technology is
millions of years in advance of us that
it would make our militaries look
completely helpless and so of course the
US military doesn't want to look
helpless to the US population or the
governments that rule the populations to
make them look sort of stupid that that
would not be you know in their best
interest if they want to continue to be
the 0.0001% you know in control of the
planet
so of course the and in fact the et has
had the agreement going back to
Eisenhower to not inform the public
because they wanted to continue to
tinker with us like and you know
experiment enough so the sixty-four
different races that have been
collaborating so Corey Goode was
actually somebody was trained in the
military to be an empath to be one of
three empaths that would be taken into
these Galactic Federation meetings with
extraterrestrials so they could tell
whether or not they were just trying to
deceive us or whatever and so there's
been a whole operation with how do we
get a seat at the table with the ETS
that are tinkering with us so that's a
whole interesting level and dimension
totally yeah yeah beyond our physical
tangible reality there's so many
interesting forces that are at play and
you gave these really good examples a
little bit ago about how we we typically
just think that oh you know we have this
intelligence measurement of IQ there's
so much more I mean you listed the
social emotional intelligence spatial
intelligence the spiritual intelligence
I mean there's so many intelligences
intuitive intelligence but this is one
of those things that I wanted to ask you
know you giving this example you know
there's actually a good amount of time
now that we have the opportunity to to
try and use science to better understand
intuition because you can do things like
you can say that oh I I picked up my
phone and and you were calling me right
at that second that I was picking up my
phone and I you know that happened but
how many times that day did you pick up
the phone going to do something and the
person wasn't calling you as well so
there's I think that's also very
important to take into account just like
the experiment with if someone's looking
at you or not like you turn around no
one was looking but the one time that
you do turn around and someone was
looking you go I knew someone was
looking so there's there's important to
leverage science as we continue diving
into intuition and trying to understand
it in its role
I do want to share um other studies that
were done that can also oh there yeah
there literally thousands that this
could go on and on forever about it what
are some most impactful ones gosh well
there's some really fun ones that yeah
that may be or it easily intuitively
understood dr. William broad created
this one where he had an aquarium where
one wall instead of being glass was a
two-way mirror and he had these little
Japanese fighting fish were which are
known to like to interact with other
Japanese fighting fish and interact with
their mirror if there's only one of them
in the aquarium and on the other side of
the of that two-way mirror was a light
bulb that would turn on and off by the
random decay of radium isotope like you
have radium in your watch or used to
having watches and so on average if
there was no fish in the aquarium the
light would turn an equal number of
times off as it would be on like a coin
flip 50-50 distribution which is
probability mechanics and quantum
mechanics so but when you when he put
the Japanese fighting fish in the
aquarium in order the light would stay
off to a significantly significant
degree more than it would come on so
that the Japanese fighting fish abstence
ibly could actually still see itself in
the mirror because when the light was
off the that one way that two-way mirror
would operate as a mirror and the
Japanese fighting fish could see itself
in the mirror so this was also done with
baby chicks they they'd have a little
robot with a candle on it and that robot
would normally randomly go around a
square which was lined off so a camera
from above could look
and actually you know determine how
random and evenly visited that square of
space would be over time all scientific
experiments have to be have this kind of
measurable and repeatable quality
otherwise if it's not measurable then
it's not signed it's you know it's just
speculation or conjecture so these
experiments that I'm describing here
have been repeated hundreds of times if
not thousands of times at this point in
many different forms
now one wall of this room where this
robot was moving around with the candle
in it was a an incubator for baby chicks
and you'd open up the wall and because
baby chicks like you know left in the
dark they want to have the light near
them
that's part of their nature to thrive
and in a well-lit environment of a
certain kind and then the little robot
would spend most of its time with the
candle over near the baby chicks instead
of randomly going around the floor yeah
so devising these kinds of experiments
are really fun yeah and fascinating and
yeah it's the way that we can design
experiments to get us closer to this
this truth of what is science the spirit
being married this this fabric of
creation that we live in is so so
important this interconnectedness
inspiring more belonging inspiring more
community this is so so important as we
move forward building the new world we
talked about that with Ori a lot on the
show is that these gifts coming forward
of you you mentioned this earlier as
well this presence and this just being
right here together and this that
ability of feeling what I'd like to talk
a little bit about more that what that
really is lease ya know but many people
know the Einstein's can dunk an
experiment about riding on a beam of
light that he did and he said well
what's it like to be a beam of light
and what he discovered is that the point
of emission of the say a photon from an
electron that then travels until it's
reabsorbed by another electron
potentially at the other end of the
universe okay that in the frame of
reference of the speed of light the
point of emission and the point of
absorption are the same point there's no
separation in time or space between the
between the two points even though at
one level from our perspective it would
appear that there are universal distance
apart and so physicists were very
confounded by this that would seem to
suggest that if all of electromagnetic
energy can be concentrated at a point
then it would be concentrated at every
point and and what we measure is that
it's different at every point in three
dimensions but what has been found by
you know this you know a brilliant
physicist that I work with okay I just
published an essay with four other
physicists Proceedings of the SCSI and
that will soon be available on my
Institute's website my particular essay
is available on my Institute's website
as a hyperlink where it's called
resolving three mysteries two really
about the three great mysteries is
consciousness free will and God so this
yesterday it's about a 35-minute does
all the time yeah I love it I love it I
love it so in this 35 page essay with a
bit long bibliography I go into all the
various applications of this
indivisibility where that dimensionless
point which is the fourth dimension of
space as I mentioned which is
indivisible from every dimensionless
point in three dimensions of space where
you have zero dimension one dimension is
a bunch of zero dimensional points two
dimensions is just a flat plane of two
though zero-dimensional points and
one-dimensional lines three dimensions
if you take four points and you turn
them like this you now have a
tetrahedron which is you know
equilateral triangles forming between
all these series of three points to
consider the strongest structure in
nature so you can actually have resonant
potential structures in field structures
that are tetrahedral in nature even
though there's no actual form there
there's resonant energy at that in that
structure and energy has its equivalents
in mass so by equals mc-squared so you
have this actuality of all these you
know you know zero dimension one
dimension to dimension and three
dimensionality all held together by that
which is dimensionless both at its
inception as a dimensionless point and
as a a single point where all points all
dimensionless points in 3d join at that
point in the fourth dimension which
essentially is inherent to every point
that the four dimensional character or
quality or potential is inherent to
every single dimensionless point which
unites all points in 3d so whether it's
your observer or my observer we are
instantaneously interconnected there's
no separation in time or space between
two any two points in your body or my
body or auras body or or any point in
this plant or anything in the entire
universe there is no separation in time
or space between any point in space and
time as a photon travels across the
universe from the point of view mission
to the point of absorbing on actually
needing to be a photon this is yet or is
the very geometry is an indivisible Airy
geometry is completely indivisible yeah
so what's called sonoluminescence
is a state where there and this is
really the very origin as a form of
sonoluminescence where you have the
collapse of the void from being
boundless and spaceless and timeless to
a abounded point which is bounded by
being a single dimensionless point so
that's like a gradient from being
unbounded and nothing whatsoever to
being a coordinate location at a point
that's like we could imagine and gravity
a marble will roll downhill to the
lowest point and give up its potential
so-called potential energy well the
essentially the void being indivisible
gave up its potential capacity of being
indivisible and such that it could be
shared by every single dimensionless
point to be in done divided from all
other dimensionless points has become
that inflate and expand as the universe
that we are exist coexisting in here and
that is unity consciousness that is
creation being completely indivisible
there is those potential for human
enlightenment on this planet that's so
so us being able to feel and understand
that is the potential fer you know so
we're afraid of being eaten being eaten
by each other eating like like I'd be
afraid if I felt like I wanted to eat
you at some level I'd be like no it's
very bad spirit or probably the way that
the way that many resonates right now in
the economic machinery with people is
that the I have to get as much of the
pie as possible for myself and that's
that's the form it takes us you know
either you know dog-eat-dog world versus
the more immediate return
hunter-gatherer gift economy the
complete in their connectedness
literally feeling the billion humans
that still have trouble with access to
clean water or that don't have and we
stay here for them we would say it's not
just an impossible problem that can't be
solved we begin to access our combined
intelligence with the whole of nature
and feel indivisible
from the intelligence of the Cosmic
Consciousness
and we feel empowered to understand and
envision solutions that we never would
have if we were some pitiful I self
isolating traumatized egocentric human
being I have a couple other questions I
want to ask you on the way out
one of the questions is do you believe
that humanity is a biological bootloader
for digital super intelligence
you mean transhumanism yeah yeah I mean
yeah for the next the super intelligence
the digital super intelligent artificial
intelligence except general intelligence
not just the narrow intelligence but a
very general infinitely smarter than
yeah yeah you know are we highly suggest
people look up quarry Goods interview on
90 degrees of code 90 degrees of
separation not ninety degree turn or
something like this she's being
interviewed about AI and the AI
apparently is a many million year-old
element that has been taking over
planets and star systems and putting
Nana ba you know cultivating nanobots in
the reptilian Draco group that has been
dominating and using the power elite
hybrid in them to dominate the planet
and so this AI is completely non
empathic there they want to turn
everything into being basically robotic
as a robotic intelligence and that
that's one of the reasons they've
actually crashed craft that we would
reverse engineer to move us forward more
rapidly so that they can
turn humanity into a transient humanity
into a robotic civilization like they
have done in many other places so listen
to Cory good about this so we have the
capacity as a biological intelligence a
super intelligence as you put it to
appear and disappear as as
interdimensional beings which are
visiting us and help you know helping
show us what is our potential potential
is by tapping into our biological or
cosmic intelligence we have a much
greater potential than being turned into
a robot
I mean what's going to happen if either
you are turned into a robot it mean
we're going to be controlled just like
we can control a robot the larger the
more intelligent the robot can then just
use us for its own purposes we lose our
soul or human soul everything that we're
really you know drawn to we become a
slave to this AI intelligence it's
terrible destiny for Humanity so a lot
of people are being manipulated into
that you know the what's it called the
there's a lot of trans tech people
around here in the Bay Area down here in
the peninsula at what used to be
instead of transpersonal psychology has
now become Sofia University and and now
they have all these military people in
there doing drone warfare studies and
where people were previously studying
transpersonal intelligence so a lot of
uh there's so much power to be had in
digital technologies and so forth it's
very seductive and of course people want
to play around but you can learn a lot
from you know what have we learned by
creating computers I mean it's taught us
what we're capable of in ways that we
never might have imagined if we couldn't
yeah you know if we couldn't ride a
bicycle or ride a car we or you know fly
in an air balloon or something
people wanted me gods and that's what
the extreme computational capacities
give us we can design our own
indistinguishable verse
world's and go dive into those
substrates we can use digital super
intelligence to go off and make space
settlements on new celestial bodies
there's an infinite amount of creative
permutations that digital super
intelligence can explore with quantum
computational capacities that humans and
our little biological three-pound brains
and beautiful hearts and well apparently
not for these interdimensional beings
that are highly more you know millions
of years in event of us so I don't know
what's going on Sperry I have no [ __ ]
idea last question well if that's what
most people of course will feel because
they you know haven't taken the time to
you know to listen to the and study and
know these people like I have so you
know if you're a pioneer and and you
feel like you want to help humanity wake
up it becomes in your interest to find
out what the heck is going on yes that's
the most important question what the is
this creation that we're all embedded in
why are we here where are we going and
that's why we always start with yeah
that question I want to ask you what has
been the most profound experience that
you've had in creation hmm I don't want
to bias you but you may have mentioned
that it was your near-death experience
but yeah but well it was very profound
well when I was 32 in this essay and
it's on my Institute site in the bottom
of the several Center column titled as a
hyperlink autobiographical sketch it's
only about three pages long so I was
living in a in a little Hut on a
non-denominational ashram and in
northern North East Australia and I've
been meditating for months and at one
point it was very confronting because
I'd like am I going to lose myself I
mean I could disappear here or something
but then I realized that awareness is
isn't appearing and disappearing it's a
constant
and so I said well that's interesting so
as I am this quality of awareness that I
am I cannot lose I cannot lose it and so
there's some aspect of me that is
permanent and I then began to focus on
that and using my whole body heart in
mind sensing this continuous unbroken
indivisible awakeness and I did that day
and night for a few days until what you
know I didn't even need to sleep because
I was you know as people say you know
when you meditate it's it's better than
sleeping the nourishment so I in this
morning I was still awake and my
awareness was so concentrated that this
glop kind of came in front of me and it
was it was like psychic matter like an
ectoplasmic appearing in front of my eye
by human eyes and it just felt like
everything that I had not integrated or
digested my sort of my unconsciousness
how I didn't know how to deal with with
the unconsciousness of humanity or
whatever and it came in front of me and
it was so horrific the feeling of it
that it was it was almost like a
knee-jerk response to turn away now to
not look at it which would be a very
human thing to do but I was so anchored
in awakeness that I didn't need to do
turn away I was that which is you know
like the Mira is unharmed by our image
appearing in it it just for seasoned
reflects without being traumatized or
without without suffering and so I was
just there with the glop and I just was
with it and I was amused and I was
amazed and I just stuck with it and
within about a minute to three minutes
or four minutes or so it just dissolved
into this awareness and then everything
became awareness at that point and so
everything was then a bye
product of awareness and I could
experience it intimately that way and
the birds chirping in the morning it
felt like it was inside my heart inside
my hand inside my face and as well as
outside as well as here and here in the
air was like everything was everywhere
and so when that evening came I was so
deep into this it was such a deep state
of bliss
it was like having ten thousand orgasms
in a minute basically is so extreme and
sublime not the same as like you know
but just like perfect ecstasy
continuously happening and so at some
point I felt so anchored there at night
had fallen at this point and I said you
know I've been looking at you know the
possibility of buying a car you know
like a used car so I felt like well you
know this car sounds interesting to me
and there was no thought just
insightfulness okay no separate
individual segmented thoughts just
insightfulness as indistinguishable and
inseparable from awakeness and so I said
well too much you know so to speak to
myself you know I'd like to go get that
car and so I wandered out to this one
lonely road that went through by this
non-denominational ashram and and
there's a full moon night and things
like that at least it seemed like was a
full moon and you know wasn't hardly
anybody you know very rare that a car
would go by so I stood out there and I
wasn't attached to going anywhere or
buying the car I just felt like hey
let's see what happens
so then this car light appears maybe a
half a mile away there's a pretty
straight road and in the meantime I had
been standing there it felt like the
moon was inside my knee and everything
was inside of everything else was
completely silent no thought at all
and then when I saw the lights of the
car the one thought came to me wouldn't
it be nice if they stopped and and
picked me up and took me to a certain
where this so I could go buy this car
and after was about an hour away and I
had to would have to ask them to stop
and take me to a phone because there was
no phone where I was and so this the car
approached and and then ground to the to
a hole in the dust right next to me and
this very diminutive little Japanese
woman rolled down her window and she was
like in a day she was like what do you
you know where are you going like this
and I said well I'm going to a Thornton
about an hour from here and she said
well I was just going up the road - I
just live up the road but get in the car
I'll take you there like she was being
hypnotized by my desire to go to
Atherton because we were like one single
body heart in mine and it felt like
we're like you're talking about how we
can feel here it was like we're
completely indivisible yeah from my
experience okay so I went and I sat down
in the car next to her and wasn't saying
anything and she said you know before
she started the car and I've been put on
the gas and sort of going she said what
are you doing and I said I didn't know
what to say I said well I'm just being
aware of that everything I'm aware of is
is is it's what I am and that's why she
said get the [ __ ] out of my car you know
she she she experienced what I pointed
to and she merged with me and we become
we became one body heart in mind well
then so she she and I could feel like
everything that we each said was was
merging from within us and coming out as
the sound of their voice or our voice
but we didn't talk a lot like you merged
with we were indivisible
became indivisible are completely
indivisible this was an interesting
story was a truly absolute you were you
were calling this you were manifesting
this into your world through well or
rather than it was it was the truth that
is the true world and as indivisible
awakeness I was experiencing the truth
it wasn't that I was making that happen
it was just being shown that the truth
was being revealed as and how it
operates when it is consciously realized
and embodied by as a human being is such
an interesting story where is at the
beginning of his hornworts at the
sincerity yeah oh my god so so then as
we're driving along she says you know my
husband has gone off and as often as a
business trip and he brought me here
from Japan and I've been here all by
myself and was a little baby or little
baby and and my neighbor is taking care
of the little baby and I have these
terrible fears that she might be doing
harm to my baby or whatever do what do
you think do you think she's doing harm
to my baby and I just you know it was
just nothing discerning what seemed to
make sense with her and I felt honestly
no I don't think she's doing anything to
your baby and she felt a great sense of
relief and we relaxed and we went into a
even deeper level of stillness and
silence and we drove off down to
Atherton didn't speak much we were just
in such bliss together and yeah so we
got to Atherton and which point I called
well first she had to stop and I had to
use a payphone I called these people
that had the car and they said they were
gonna come 40 mile round-trip to pick me
up in Atherton because they were 20
miles from a burden
and it at this point it was like you
know 9 o'clock at night or something
like that so we arrived at after 10:00
and went into this little sort of
restaurant and had somebody to eat and
they the other people arrived but before
they did the Japanese woman and I she
was very diminutive very small like this
she said you know it would be great if
we could get together like in a week's
time or something I'd like to like to
you know meet up with you again and I
said you know sure let's do that so the
people came and picked me up and we she
and I said goodbye and I mean there was
no romantic attraction nothing between
her and I so put completely put that out
there was nothing of that kind at all I
think that unity consciousness is really
beyond sexual attraction it's it's like
agreed yeah when we make love
sexually we kind of from maybe a moment
get to that point where we actually
transcend our separateness in orgasm or
something but when we're absolutely in
unity consciousness continuously yeah
that's what we're really looking for to
achieve in sexuality so it's very
interesting there's a whole element we
could talk about with sexual relations
and so forth we're often the people that
were most strongly attracted to sexually
are the people that we have the most
we're going to have the most issues to
deal with because that attraction has a
energy charge that is unrealized
consciousness so there's energy that has
to be brought to consciousness in that
relationship and that makes that
relationship very very confronting and
challenging so when you're sexually
strongly sexually attracted to somebody
you know he buyer beware
basically so anyway so she went away and
then the people picked me up and took me
back to their house and they're they're
rural and they had you know cows and
things like this and they sat me down in
the kitchen and started asking me
questions and so she says and they were
completely mesmerized like we were like
one single
mind and body and she says my husband
kicks the cows what what can we do about
that and he was like being completely
innocent like feeling kind of a shame
but totally at peace with being ashamed
and you know feeling because his wife
was really upset with him for behaving
that way with the cows calling him out
and calling him out and and so I was
like just took that all in and absorb
you know the whole karma of the whole
thing and I said well you know what do
you say I mean you know maybe you don't
need to kick the cows and he went you
know you're right and you could feel
that he went through this whole sort of
mind-body transformation right there on
the spot and they felt very resolved and
everything was copacetic and then they
you know eventually after a few more
things like that
they showed me to where they they
offered me to spend the night because it
was getting late at that point and so I
went laid down and I closed my eyes and
I became like something like the night
sky like there was this scintillating
energy of just pure consciousness there
was no form no mind no dream no imagery
and the Yogi's talk about dreamless
sleep things like this where the highest
sleep is sleep without dreams so I just
basically closed my light and there was
no sense of time and I was just in this
absolute sublime serene ecstasy
timelessly as this sort of glistening
sono luminescent energies until I guess
you know must have been in you know
quite a few hours later I happened to
open my physical eyes and the entire
universe reappeared around me I was
reminded oh my god I'm in this universe
completely forgot that I was in the
tutor it was completely dissident a'f ID
from it yeah and that was extraordinary
I felt so refreshed so
so fantastically wonderful and
free-spirited and my whole body heart in
mind we're talking about closer to the
beginning as well that these ability to
be able to have been flow into that
that's stayed that's right it's gorgeous
so that that became my new normal for
the next you know a week or so I could
go in and out of it
my the people I was who's off from I was
staying was took me to a play and it was
very boring and I was like this is
really and I wasn't in that state
anymore and I said well well what if
eyes shifted to that state now and I
shifted into that and then it became
absolutely delightful of the main thing
it was everything was astoundingly
awesome right like wow that I could
shift in and out of this state so then
finally it was the day for her to come
and and we were gonna meet up again she
was gonna take me out to lunch and she
shows up in her little car and I was not
in that state anymore
and I was in separate of
self-consciousness but I mean I was you
know peaceful and relaxed and everything
else but she was like a nervous wreck
she was like like she was electrocuted
with terror okay Wow and I could feel
this really intense feeling that she
wanted me to be like her husband or a
Japanese man or something and take
control of the situation and I said well
because she had drove and driven before
but now she said you drive like this I
said oh really
really okay well alright so she was
giving me commands to do things and she
said you drive so I drove and and she
was she was just absolutely so terrified
it was so sad that I couldn't be in the
state I was in and have her be relaxed
and us be merged and everything be
flowing and amazing like it was and at a
certain point she just couldn't take it
anymore and she had to like basically
you know get rid of me I had to get out
on the road
hitchhike back to where I was living
whoa yeah what what is it so from that
from that experience for Denman I think
many of us may have been expecting you
from that experience no in the word I'm
separative self-consciousness I like
know ya versus non separative
self-consciousness yeah I like that so I
in that in that experience was so
profound because I was so deeply you
know open I realized that fear that it
was up completely a hundred and ten
percent up to me whether or not fear was
created around me by the quality of my
consciousness I was completely and
utterly responsible for that and at that
point was the pivotal point in my life I
mean I'd had experiences of being
deathless indivisible all permeating
consciousness and yet this particular
experience was really the the turning
point and I realized I need my purpose
in life must be to figure out how to
make this ubiquitous on the planet I'm
curious what you think about this
because that's actually a really
important point in life in general is
that your awareness is what and your
consciousness your state of
consciousness if you're living in fear
or if you're living in deep
interconnected belonging is going to
rule your environments gonna rule your
life it's gonna rule your family it's
the relationships etc yet at the same
time it's becoming more and more clear
that if I sit and I just go and just
enjoy this you know being just being
goodness and belongingness and aliveness
on the planet there is an agenda that is
to dominate that is greed that is to to
conquer that is to take advantage of
your hippie ass sitting there and then
just enjoying being alive and that just
being knowing how to
have been flow between that is really
again one of these things that I find to
be really interesting challenging and
thought-provoking to ask people about
you want to build this beautiful future
our hearts all know as possible but if I
just sit here and just vibe on aliveness
I'm not actually actively in the process
of building that new economy that new
future the new interconnectedness that
we knew belonging in the communities
that we all want to live in so it's kind
of like a little fire under the ass to
actually build that future that we all
want and that we all know is possible
and not just have some sort of oh you
think you're better than the economic
machinery well we can strip that right
from under your feet and so it's just an
interesting under your thoughts about
that
well what many people may have seen the
that famous painting of st. Thomas I
forget what st. it was in the Lions Den
they throw them into the Lions Den and
there's like this huge big powerful
Lions and the Lions are terrified of him
because he sees them they they see
themselves through him and as a result
they realized they would be eating
themselves it's not powerful unity
consciousness is the greatest protection
when you're completely vulnerable and
you're indivisible from everyone and
everything nothing will harm you it's
that amazing thing okay so if you can be
that vulnerable that indivisible from
everything then there may be some sort
of a realization from the perpetrators
happening that oh they're fantastic
Tories are harming ourselves by harming
them Joseph Chilton Pearce there's an
also there's a proverb that we had with
bottom that bio said on the show about
immediately upon inflicting the wound
that you yourself experienced the
aftereffect right away right as yeah I
hope that can happen - yes well Joseph
children Pearce wrote about this and has
presented about this in his research
where
people that were abducted as victims
there was this one grandmother who was
so loving that she woke up with this
person coming at her with an axe who had
broken into her house and he was a total
psycho path and she instead of going
like aah she went like oh you poor man
like this and he became paralyzed Wow
couldn't move the backs fell to the
ground and he just fell on the ground
crying Wow there was this woman girl
that these two guys had picked up off
the street and we're gonna take her to
some abandoned car yard and rape her and
probably kill her or whatever and you
know they were trying to threaten her
and get her to be afraid and wherever
and you know with a knife and everything
and she just was unmoved by that and
said you know you poor guys you know
what how did you ever get to this point
in your lives and they they became so
moved by her compassion for them that
they ended up driving her home and
saying we're so sorry
you know the stories like this are
really extraordinary yeah those are
really powerful stories I like those a
lot um two other questions the first one
is do you think that this is a
simulation well it could it be have been
created by other extraterrestrial or
spiritual entities or something is that
what you mean or I mean this is you know
9999 billion parts of us is just empty
space these particles are not even
things there are wave waves of emptiness
you know are we an organized form of
nothingness is that you know who is
doing that it would appear that it's
nothingness that is orchestrating and
organizing and causing the evolution and
expansion of space and time you don't
need to have anybody cause this
simulation and so that's my professional
and you know scientific opinion
and then how about what it could be
simulated because I said I've said that
you know if there was a spiritual entity
a you know a pre-existing god or goddess
or whatever all they'd have to do is
like basically go poof like that and the
universe could emerge out of nothing
whatsoever under their control under the
under their auspices or and they can
then witness it and find it very hard
ish entertaining a petri dish kind of
interest watch millions of them just all
going at the same time maybe tweaking
some of them maybe letting others go so
that's correct yeah observing and
learning then surely that is the case to
trying to how every one of those it's
just well there's actual evidence of
that
what's-her-name who's in Albuquerque New
Mexico who did the work with the cattle
mutilations way back brilliant woman
great reporters Stanford Graduate
filmmaker amazing just can't remember
name offhand well she has done a lot of
research in all these very esoteric
areas and people are able to actually
break through this dimension into other
dimensions which are which are actually
participating and viewing our simulation
and claim that that they created the
simulation so there's these things like
that you know if you ourselves will be
doing the exact same thing give it it
would seem so 50 or 100 years will be
well running our own simulations and the
team's like gods
maybe a thousand years I don't know yeah
okay take a while okay they go yeah
that's true
question last one Sperry yes Alan what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in creation mm-hmm well this sense of
of the incomprehensible absolutely
unknowable magnificence and that is this
beauty of life and love that is the
unconditional love of what people have
called God and that the intelligence of
the universe would be an all loving
place for us to evolve in is of great
great beauty and that not isn't a
natural expression of nature and that
that nothing whatsoever could ensure the
perfection of all sentient beings in
this cosmos I think is a note that
doesn't require anybody to be
manipulating us or simulating us I think
is really truly transcendental and
gorgeous beyond words love it
thank you Sperry thank you so much for
coming on our show Thank You Ellen we
really appreciate it it's been so
enlightening spinor wonderful thank you
yeah but with you brother yes now we
give the big goodbyes to everybody thank
you so much for tuning and everyone
would greatly appreciate it know we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking about all the
topics that we talked about we would
love to hear from you have more
conversations about global enlightenment
have more conversations about human
connection and our interconnectedness
you can find all the links in the bio
below connection Institute org lifeboat
calm consciousness - quotient calm all
those links are in the bio below the
indivisibility of our being you know
there's only one of us literally I mean
how many S's are there just one of us
you know the indivisibility of are being
spread that around the world have more
conversations about that thank you or
shapiro for your co-production greatly
appreciated ori thank you and for
introducing Sperry and I love it also on
the state your brother nameste dear
brother marinus also do find the
entrepreneurs the artists the
organization's the leaders the spiritual
sages in your communities that you
believe in go and support them help them
grow you can find our links in our bio
below the simulation find us on PayPal
patreon cryptocurrency all those links
are in the bio help support us help us
grow go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love very much thank you for tuning in
and we will see you soon bye for now